in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Matthew
and Catherine are with us hey guys how
are you hey we're doing wonderful how
are you doing better than I deserve
welcome welcome where do you guys live
we are from Louisville Kentucky very fun
not a bad drive down to Nashville no
just a few hours good to have you so
you're here to do a debt-free scream yes
sir very cool how much do you how much
did you pay we don't know anything they
don't know anything
thanks we we paid off a little under
30,000 good for you and my how long did
that take just about a year and a half
okay
making what kind of money making a
little under sixty thousand okay
excellent very cool what kind of debt
was this a little bit of everything we
had a little bit a few thousand in
credit cards a couple thousand in
medical debt but the vast majority of it
was student loans okay so what happened
one and a half years ago that starts you
on this journey well we were dating at
that point or had just gotten engaged
and we had actually we actually found
you before we found each other
we I had a friend of mine who kind of
turned me on to your Total Money
Makeover book because I had just gotten
out of college just bought a car and I
was this whole bonding car with a debt
just felt weird it didn't feel right and
so he kind of turned me in your
direction and then can't kind of had
gone to your FPU class all right through
her church very cool
okay so she was already smart okay so
you'd gone to the class but it didn't
take okay and so then you get engaged
and you start talking about this then
what happened well we had actually
decided to do the they did another round
at her church of the FPU so then we did
it together ah there you go and so we're
doing it together and we she kind of
started doing some of the credit-card
debt before we get married and then once
we were married and we had the two
incomes we just really just gizelle
intensity Wow just plowed right through
it then okay so it's really the first
order of business mathematically in your
marriage was to get this in a tacit oh
yeah all right very cool
so now that you've done this together
for the first year and a half of your
marriage you can do anything can't you
pretty much yeah
why teaches you to work together it
makes you do all these things that a lot
of people married ten years don't know
how to do so it gives you a real head
start on relationship stuff as well as
knocking out the debt very cool
congratulations thank you so who brought
the most debt actually all of it was my
debt
oh he got his car paid off before we
were even engaged all of the student
loan debt was mine all of the credit
cards is mine his medical wasn't that
expenses like $2,000 so a little bit
yeah it was all me
very cool well you're worth it it's good
very well done you guys so what was the
hardest part of this over the year and a
half for you all
I'll let caddy answer that one hardest
part is me I am not disciplined at all
he's got all the money smarts and I just
want to spend I don't like to say if I'm
definitely a shopper so getting on a
budget was definitely difficult for me
but since we started our marriage off
that way it really helped our marriage I
think and it helped me grow as a person
helped me realize that I'm very selfish
I just want all of this stuff and saving
and like only having fifty dollars a
blow money is really helping me to
figure out okay I really don't need that
and yeah that's it it's just helped me
grow as you're giving yourself
boundaries yes definitely very good
that's good that's awesome yeah that's a
very cool position to be in
well congratulations you guys thank you
very very well done
all right it's Matthew and Katherine
from Louisville Kentucky $30,000 paid
off in a year and a half
making just under sixty a year count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one
and the crowd goes wild
I love it I love it I love it very well
done